There's a breakfast cereal that's sold in Greece called Cow Biota, Kai.
And some some people have suggested that a subliminal effect on me when I was when I was writing the name on the other day, Tony Danza.
I put another sample up here. Oh, OK.
Oh, OK. We've got a competition for us. Oh.
Oh gosh. Aw. Thanks very much. It was announced yesterday.
Thank you. OK, so this is some people thought that this had some relation to the logo for protests.
I had to bring it now. This is the Wizards class.
And I also see some people in here who's who.
Who said they were going to come in anyway, even though they did.
They hadn't used tech that much. They thought by osmosis they would like to know what it would mean.
Maybe that maybe they'd like to know what they would be able to understand in a year.
However, I'm going to pitch my remarks that the people who are really who are really experts.
Because after four years of experience with this than learning every few months,
I think of another thing that I opened my eyes to, something I didn't believe I could do with tech found a way to do it.
I'm trying to communicate these things to you this weekend, to the end,
to the people who are going to be designing macro packages for others and people who are going
to be troubleshooting and and and possibly doing something with the implementation so on.
So we're going to go into the really the really arcane stuff, the really mysterious stuff.
And I plan in in the definitive tech manual when it comes out to have a new Appendix D for dirty tricks.
And I'm going to explain some of those, you know, actually,
probably this week I'll explain even some things that are dirtier than I would dare put in in in print.
So. So see where have now in order to in order to get started today,
I want to talk about the basic and a detail level, exactly what tech looks like inside.
And and then make sure that we understand the primitives, the tools that we're trying to bend to our to our uses.
And so what I did was I made up in a sample file that is really does nothing at all that anyone in his right mind would ever do,
except that it does cause affected to print out a whole bunch of stuff indicating how high tech functions.
And so that and there's a handout that you can follow. Matter of fact, let's pass this around.
Can we start this going around the.
So I made up this file called Goofy, which is which is the first page of the handout.
And then the the rest of the handout is the is the Aerostar temp file that you get from from running goofy.
And the idea was to to show you how that's in fine print.
You'll notice that the errors. But to show you exactly the kinds of information you can get tech to print for you if you want to.
If you want to do troubleshooting as well as to get a good feeling as to exactly what tech is doing because, well, this printout shows reading texts,
thought processes, if you can dignify and by that name, you know, it tells what what tech's view of the situation is and when.
And you want to know exactly what that is. If you want to if you're going to advance to the to the extremes of what can do.
OK. So now this this file does does nothing useful.
You said I start out just by putting in basic.
But then I'm going to really find a whole bunch of things and I'd be finding them in such a way that when the definitions are used,
we'll be able to recognize them. So, for example, by by saying tracing and turning almost everything on, I'll be getting a lot of output.
I'm usually a user, of course, doesn't doesn't seal itself or I'm going to tell text to print out a lot of stuff.
Everything except pauses. In other words, it doesn't parse on when it hits the DDT or something like that now.
So a little line penalty. I made a hundred and four broken nine point one hundred five.
So when you see later on tech inserting a penalty of a hundred and four, you know that this is because it thought there was a little line there.
And things like that. OK. But break after a binary operation or relation.
And so on. So we'll be if we if these penalties occur, then we'll be able to know what they are.
That's what these. Parameters actually are intact. And usually they're set to default values.
I set the age size to 201 this size to all to the par and down to two point or three math around 2.0 four.
This is a space around a math formula. And then I made the top baseline 100 points.
That's the baseline of the top thing on the page. And and other glue is going to be inserted in order to make it come out to us.
It's possible that the first the first thing on a page is going to have a baseline hundred points from the very top margin.
And and so I chose a number like one hundred, which would be easy to check for the arithmetic to see if it came out right.
Max depth. I tried to make a characteristic decimal value here.
This is the depth of of a of the page at the bottom of the page that tries to make the
base line at the top and the bottom both come out to be added at the right place.
So if you say that you V size is ten inches, well then then the bottom baseline is supposed to be 10 inches from the top of margin.
And this top baseline is supposed to be governed by this guy, if possible.
Now, if you if actually there's a box that's that's so big that you can't do this, then.
Then take those the next best thing. And the max depth is one of the things that it's, for example, at the very bottom baseline.
If the if the bottom box has a has a depth more than this amount,
then the bottom box is going to be shifted up so that it's depth where we're at is actually redefined to be this.
That's what that next step is. It's baseline skip by making twelve points.
But I'm putting so that you can recognize the baseline skip.
We, we use the plus and minus part to be three o one and four on the mindscape will be three or two and four.
So this we will be able to check whether or not whether we're our blue is coming from a par skip.
The give after paragraph displays gifts of different kinds.
Top skip is in biomes. Gifts are for inserts.
If there were any tab, Skip is in alignment's and powerful skip.
There is the space at the end of a paragraph that closes the last line of the paragraph.
An ex spaceship is a space after a period or a question mark or something like that in the middle of a paragraph.
No. Now I define top seven by itself. These are things that that that separate your inserts from from the right for us to text on a page.
And so we will be recognized when they occur because it says T for top and B for bottom.
And now comes the text that I'm going to be doing that I'm going to be doing your homework this week.
And the first your first homework assignment for tomorrow is to explain every No.
On the second page of the handout. Second, third, fourth features of the handout you get so that you understand what all those numbers are.
And I'll I'll give you a list.
Most of today's talk I'm just gonna be talking about about give it give a basic idea of the understanding of those numbers.
But actually, you should look at over to the point where you understand everything,
because this is exactly what this file tells tech to do, and it's doing it faithfully.
And you should be able to look at those and see why it does it otherwise. Ask me to ask for the S tomorrow.
But we've got to get the basics understood now. OK.
Before I go into this, the rest of this file though. I got it. I got it. I should review quickly the basics of of of boxes and then.
Namely if you namely tech is is a two dimensional this processing language.
It makes it makes lists either in a horizontal direction or the vertical direction.
And then. And these lists can be the glue units.
It can be set in these lists and make to make a box. And then that box can can participate in another list and so on.
Now the rules are in horizontal box. The horizontal box is made from taking the elements of the horizontal list.
Whatever. These boxes are lining up the reference points. All in all, all in the same place horizontally.
And then if there there might be glue between here and the glue is the glue is computed by other means.
But I am trying to say what happens when you put boxes together and took into one other box?
And then the the final the resulting box. So it starts at its reference point is going to be the reference point of the very first box on the list.
Or if if the list actually starts with glue, it will be it will be in the same line as that.
But over but over here. Suppose there were glue here. The first item, we're glue.
So then the reference point for the whole box will be at the very left of the whole thing.
And then the height of the whole box is going to be the maximum of the height and depth will be the maximum one of these.
But never is negative or zero unless you've specified some some fancy thing.
It's not very easy to get a box of negative hype. I think if you see a V box two minus one point, you can get a box.
That's one negative, one point high. But that's about the only way.
It's not breathing. Most the time it comes out negative hype.
So if I had a no box that was only below the baseline, I, I could I lowered it or something.
Then I think the hype was to come out zero. Anyway, the final H box now has a height width in a depth measured from the baseline.
It's not symmetrical. We don't, it doesn't you know, only has these three things.
Not not for that reason is that although I considered at early stage making the thing of symmetrical,
this would cause so much more memory and it would only help for setting Hebrew
in things that I didn't bother to put it into the whole into the whole skin.
So there's only these three things like that with reference point is always at the left hand.
Now that's a horizontal box. And when you when you start when you start displaying a horizontal box, you know the coordinates of its reference point.
Then you locate everything else from that. If it's glue, you move to the right.
If it's by the by the proper amount. And then if it's a box, you see, you know, the reference point for where you are at that point.
You skip by the width of the box. Now the vertical lists are computed.
You can say move left with a vertical list. And and we get and we get different reference points in these individual boxes that might
be put into a vertical is the when the whole thing is put into finally a box Reeboks,
then the fact the the reference point is computed to be the reference point of the bottom one in the list.
And that's the last thing in the list were glew blasting list is glue. Then it's then it's after the glue right below the glue.
So the depth would always be zero in a case where the last item analysis is not a box.
The the the, the v the reference point. This that this thing that was moved left gets ignored.
It doesn't it doesn't stick. Get you. I'll stick out it because we have only three dimensions.
So the height of this thing will be the height all the way to the height of the top box or
whatever glue is there and the width will be the maximum width of the on the whole thing.
And the depth will be the depth of the bottom box if it was a box. Otherwise the depth is zero.
Now these these basic rules for constructing boxes are used to do everything.
So it's important that you've got that in mind. And there is something else that isn't exactly clear.
Namely. But so what? How do you typeset this thing?
Sometimes when when when you have negative glue in there,
it's not clear whether the negative glue occurs when the backspacing occurs before or after a box.
And here's the rule. You start out at the at the reference point and you go up to the height of the inside of
each box is sort of reference point plus height is your is your standard starting place.
And then then you then you go through the V list starting at reference point plus height and moving downwards.
So to get so. So if so the reason.
So if somebody says for example v box to ten point and then you have some box here, box zero followed by vertical stretching or shrinking.
Compare that to V box to ten point vertical stretch or shrink box zero.
Now what's going to happen in these two case? In both case, we're gonna get a box of ten points higher.
This is the height of the box. We don't control the depth. That is the height of the box is ten points.
And in the first case, you go up ten points from the reference point of your final box.
And then here comes back zero, the box zero. This is the top left corner of box zero.
And then VSS adds enough stretching or shrinking to make this to make the depth come out.
Zero in height to be ten point. On the other hand, if you put the VSS first and then back to zero.
I'm sorry, this is case A. And this is case B. B, you start here.
You go up ten points and then you do as much stretching or shrinking as necessary.
But the final box is gonna be proposition here. Box zero is going to have a reference point right at the same as the reference point of that V box.
And it's going to be ten points high. But the box zero is gonna be sitting there at the same position.
And the depth of this box is going to be the same as the depth, the box zero.
So so that's the there's quite a difference there.
And you have to understand that the rule for expanding of a box in terms of really relocate first the upper right corner and go down.
Upper left corner and go downwards. When expanding. Reebok's expanding each box.
We started the reference point and go, go rightwards.
And these are two slightly different things which should be understood if you're going to do anything tricky.
Now, let me see. Yeah.
Question on that particular box.
Based on this way, this have at the very bottom box of boxes zero five.
If you say if I want to, if I want to get a certain depth, if I want to get a certain depth,
then I can put a I can say VSS and I can put a box with a certain depth here at the end of the list.
And I would just say, I don't quite know, oh, can we have it on the screen?
He'd like to see what I was trying. If I put it in the second example.
And the second example. This is the last box in the list. OK. OK, so the basics for.
For constructing boxes, I just told you then close on on vertical.
Let's go and look at the things that can go inside the boxes which are shown in which are shown in this thing here.
Now, we started out goofy by a by a paragraph that has a hanging indentation of a hanging indentation, a hundred points.
That means then that after the first line, it's just me.
This default is after one line. So the first line is going to be each side is two hundred and one wide.
The next line is going to be one hundred one point wide and shifted.
Right, 100 points. Now then it starts out with the words sill and then slanted.
Cute accent l y italic correction. OK, so silly comes in.
And now this. This of course starts a paragraph. And so. So here is here's the beginning of a paragraph, by the way, after it,
after this silly paragraph gets going a while in the middle of the paragraph, there's a DDT which is displaying what I'm about to show you.
So the DDT, by putting DDT in and having having this bit set in tracing it means that that time of DDT,
I'm going to get a display of everything that tech is doing. Well, this next this line here, SL expands into Kurr fund.
And that was. That's because I'm also expanding macros here. I'm not really interested in expanding the control sequences.
So here we are. It's in horizontal at this point where the DDT occurred in horizontal mode in a space factor.
One space factor is used to control the space.
After that, it's usually one. But after after a comma, it's one and a quarter.
And this this changes so that it it moves slightly more stretch ability after a common things like this.
The space factor is the. That's our current space fact.
Now, the beginning of the paragraph started out with this thing, which was the paragraph indentation.
A paragraph indentation is either a box with nothing in it, but it has a width.
Width is equal to the amount of the indentation which we just described by pairing them to be two point or three points.
That's why indentation is there. Then we get the S i.
L. in font A. So this means a character. This. But now. Now this is after that box comes and that comes the character.
These are all the things that are in the horizontal. The current horizontal list. And when I get to a V box here, the V box is in the list.
But the dots underneath this say looking inside the V box.
That's what's inside the box. But this this part as a unit is only one entry in the list because of these points in the first column.
So if you look in this on the first column, everything that doesn't have a point when there's a point, that means that these things are grouped OK.
And similarly, when there's two points, that means that these two are where we're a unit.
So. So there's boxes inside of boxes in that case. Now we've got to solve the next.
So the first three things for four things and lists of the indentation as the I and the L.
Then comes a box and this box represents the accent. Let her out.
OK. We switch to a slanted font and we aksenov the letter L and this was the way I put the accent on it.
The V box is by the way. It gives the height and depth of the box or the height of the box is nine point four.
Depth is zero. And this is the width. Whenever you have a box you see the dimensions of it, height, depth and width.
And so the first thing in the V box is a is is an H box.
This is the accent actually. Acute accent character number 16 is X, 16 is where the thing lives in the font for the accent shifted.
This was shifted in order to center it is shifted the left little bit. The accent was for a was was made probably for our character.
That was a little wider than an L. So it had to shift Issacson a little bit to the left.
That shift as is taken into accomplished that the amount of slanting, the fact it has to raise this accent,
the accent in the phone is made as if it was to go over a letter X has to go over letter L, it has to be moved up.
The amount of moving was computed by make my setting the height of the V box so that I
figured out how high I want in the accent to be and I might change that height there.
Then I put in enough glue to, to, to stretch or shrink to that to make it come out.
Right. And finally, the last thing in the V box is this letter L, which which is the X in a letter.
And since it's the last thing in the V box, the depth of this letter is what caused the death of the V box to be zero.
And the L itself is X, and it appears on the base line where it should rest.
So that's the that's what an X and a character looks like as far as the as far as tech is concerned in the horizontal list.
It's a V box. And so we've got an S I l v box in a Y in that list.
So the question was that we of the whole box smaller than the width of the axis.
That's because. The use the width of the letter L for that purpose.
This is for this V box was not computed by a V packaging,
but this was this this width was was was unilaterally set so that it would come out to be the width of the extended letter.
But the width of the accent. Yeah. Here it proves it. The accent was was white.
The accent was a white box but it. But I had to shift it left in order to make it work with the accent.
Really doesn't affect the the the V box that you built for an X and a letter.
It's only used to compute how much you have to shift it to keep it center. Now the Y then comes the italic correction.
Oh no. I ask for a correction after that. Why. So that's this H box with nothing in it.
Well a width of eight five one nine is the italic correction.
No, it doesn't. Whenever a color correction comes along.
Tech looks to see what the last thing in the velis twice and looks at. Correction of that character.
It's not a letter gives you an error message saying italic correction can only follow a letter.
But if you if you had finished SL and you know, and done anything else,
even change the base and skip or whatever, then you come to a tallit correction.
It says, oh, I'm in horizontal mode. What was the last thing that I did? Not horizontal mode. Get the italic correction from that tally.
Correction is something a goat that belongs to the letter Y. This when I say front end letter Y.
This is a reference to texts, information about font in character number up octal one sixty two or whatever it is, 161.
And in, in that table it'll tell what the height depth and tell correction in width are of, of every character question.
Oh yeah. There's a microphone and you push the red button when you turn. I was just wondering what the crew set of zero on two of the lines.
Oh, yeah. Like, I'm I'm glad you asked that or not really.
I don't understand why this glue's that zero came out. That means that it's epsilons, very small.
But I don't know why it got very small. I think the tallit correction must put a very tiny.
So there isn't gonna make any difference in order to in order to keep something from getting disappearing in the middle of Masimo.
But I forget I really forget why this was said zero. Is there. Just forget it.
The glue that is usually the amount that you multiply glue by now here, for example, and the glue that was negative zero.
This means it was negative but positive. But but but but but not exactly zero.
And when it gets multiplied by by this well, since it's negative, we're gonna use them for the minus factors in the glue.
So that that whatever that is is going to be multiplied by ten thousand here,
one hundred thousand year and going to give the true amount of space between those two.
And and you just can't see it isn't precision isn't enough to see exactly what it is on this one.
I don't understand why it has a booth set in there. Sorry, I may be off.
Maybe you should go out. I wondered about that too.
The next clue here is the space between words. So let's go back and see what all that came out of typing this silly thing here.
Now, the next the next thing we type is a space. And then Kaixi are discretionary hyphen in real life.
And then I'm lowering a box. Well, let's see what I'm doing.
A lower 20 points, a box, an empty box. And then I did a Topps top insert of something or other and then a comma.
So now what's going on in horizontal more? Well, a space. Letter K.
Letter E that are a discretionary hyphen, an N reallife.
And then a lowered box that lower twenty point V box of thirty point.
This is just a box that's empty. Thirty points high and it got lowered by 20 points.
And then a top insert. This is a top insert in the middle of a paragraph.
It means that this is something that has to go on the same page as as this line of the paragraph.
Top insert is if it appears in the middle of a paragraph, you know, that means wherever this page is for this line of I find on.
I want this insert to go on that same page. And they're talking sort of each box is is there then comes a comma and a carriage return.
So that's the next thing in this case. To see what happened. Did it. OK. So first came the space between words.
This is this comes out of the font. The font tells you what space to use.
Between between words and computer modern that we get out of basic is takes a it
takes one third of an M plus one sixth of an M minus one one ninth of an M r.
The two are the are the spacing that you usually get. Then comes Kaixi notice there the gist.
It's sort of I guess it's justice that the word kerning, the word turn gets turned inside,
namely there's a little bit of space taken out between the K and E to make them look just a little bit better to put the E a little closer to the K.
You really can't see that on the low resolution devices, but on high resolution ones, you can see it fine and not so.
So that's that's this is a kurnit good. Went that got inserted went Wintek saké.
It said look and see what the next letter is, if it's a year and or a few.
The small number of things after a K that will cause kerning then Tekle insert that into the middle of the list.
This isn't gonna interfere with the hyphenation algorithm question. Usually ligatures the same.
Exactly the same. Yeah. K could be followed by but yeah, it looks ahead in the same method for ligatures and kerning.
It was used to make substitutions at that point. So this was brought together a little bit to make the word Kurn look look a little more beautiful,
except that we aren't ever going to look at this funny output next.
This here is the discretionary hyphen that was put in there and notice as a fine associated with it.
So that if the if a this discretionary is another thing that can appear in the list,
then if it's a discretionary, that means that it's possible to break here.
You have to pay a penalty for breaking if you do break.
Use this character and there's another discretionary coming in a minute that's not quite the same.
Then comes the end. In the end, after the real hyphen, following a real hyphen, I put it discretionary with zero in here.
Now, if you actually look at this, it says Fonte at Sine and the character zero.
That's really zero zero because this is zero character zero.
And that that's a special case of discretionary which says don't insert any character just
below it is a legal break and you pay that and you pay a penalty for an explicit hyphen,
has an explicit hyphen penalty. The apostrophe is to make this octal.
So this is an actual zero. In general, any character that isn't isn't isn't asking.
Ordinary ASCII printing character like an end or a minus sign will print with an actual code in front of it then.
So that was so after after a hyphen or a dash. Like that, you're going to get one of these discretionary zeros in there.
That's going to be the thing that causes a possible break to occur to the hyphenation routine.
Otherwise, you get a discretionary thing with a particular fund character code in mind.
Reebok's is the next thing. And this money box was 30 feet high and nothing wide.
Still, I don't see why the glue that printed. Maybe maybe it computed something there.
But it's Epsilon anyway, but shifted 20 points.
That's down Monov shift. What if for something in a horizontal list means how much down to shift?
And so that's that's why it was it was lowered in in the source text.
Arthur. Mike it about the low discretionary height.
And does that mean there's a novel in that character? No, it means that the discretionary doesn't look at it.
There's no way to hyphenate with that with a five zero character zero.
In fact, you know, you can.
That's not to the amount of discretionary things that you can do in prison.
Version of tech is rather limited. It has to be. It has to.
It can only be a multiplication sign or or or something in character positions or sixty seven or something, wherever hyphen is in ASCII code.
But it doesn't get put in. But you can't, you can't very easily describe to take a macro that says insert a discretionary A here right now.
That would have to be an extension. Top insert is the next thing that we did in that, in that input in the top insert meeting.
Remember that said something that is going to be inserted on this page. Now, that appears right now in the horizontal list.
In the paragraph, Behler is going to is going to take this top insert and after the line is set,
it's going to move the top insert out into the vertical is that the line appears.
So this this paragraph is going to be broken into lines, maybe five lines that maybe for whatever whatever line this this one had a top insert in it.
The top insert is going to be moved out of this box and brought down following it in the vertical list later on.
So then so that the tech will know to insert to insert the thing on the same page as the as the line containing the insertion note inside,
that was just a box containing a letter A. Nothing interesting about that, except here's some glue after it.
See what that is. That's the top skip glue that we put in there because we said the top skip was point three of plus three or seven points.
So that's a dead giveaway that this is the top skip glue here.
Top skipping, but Skip are two things that that are sort of anomalous in tech language.
Most the time I've used Ockham's Razor and not put in things that were easy to put in with macros and so on.
But at the time I put in top skip and basket,
I thought that that would handle a lot of things that later on I had to put other extensions in detec for better footnote handling and so on.
That made this made it probably I know it's not really a it's a little frill to have in the language most the time.
I didn't put in Frails, but this was in there from the beginning. So you get this top skip automatically inserted every time.
If it's not zero, then came a comma after the top insert and then came the glue.
After the space. After the comma. Now the space after comma is, as I said, the space factor is a little different after a comma.
Therefore, the glue wasn't. Three point three plus one point six.
But it was three point three plus 2.0. You see.
Use it, it'll stretch a little bit more after comma, shrink a little bit less after a car because of the space fact that was higher.
You multiply this by the space factor and divide that by the space fact. That's what it is.
Now you can change the space vector to whatever you want by control sequence, space vector.
Now, following this, what comes in our source file. So we finish this line.
Weird as it is, we already find out, though, in this line, all kinds of things that can exist in horizontal is not just boxes, not just glue.
Also Kernes discretionary is inserts. OK.
We haven't seen anything else.
So I guess this currence discretionary inserts and characters, of course V boxes in HD boxes that have appeared in this list.
Now the next thing is a math formula.
DocuSign B plus equals D unassigned period space. Let's go and see what came from that.
Well now I said, I said that math around was 2.0 four.
So that means we're putting some space 2.0 four points of space for a space around every math formula.
So here it is. It's given in terms of occurrence of two point four.
This is different from Glew because it's not allowed as a place to break a line.
And but there's something special about what happened.
If a line breaks at that glue, then this current would actually go away so that the formula would start left justified on the next line.
Hyphenation zero and hyphenation one which comes up later.
This brackets the math formula around every math formula. We have to hyphenation things that are inserted in the list.
This tells Tek not to use its normal hyphenation not to not to break after glue and not
to try hyphenating any combinations of letters that you might find in that formula.
It would look a little funny if if if your math. You just have to spell a word that got hyphenated between Lysol.
So that's shut. So this is hyphenate shuttle hyphenation off. Turn it back on again around the formula.
So this will occur in a horizontal is the hyphenation control? No.
Then the math formula itself was B plus equals V. Well what actually happened while B got said in italics.
Fine, fine. G. Then came a glew and a plus sign. This glue is this is called the OP.
The space around operators and. And this is inserted before and after plus signs.
So. So we've got glue before and after that plus sign. And there's a penalty stuck.
Before the second glue. This means it's possible to break after that plus sign if you have to, with paying a penalty of one hundred and six.
That one or six is the thing that we said was the Byrn outbreak parameter.
So so one or six means that this was this power specifying how much we want to break after a penalty if you don't want to break.
I mean, I there an operation. If you don't want to break after one hour operation of course you said was Brammer
to a thousand and a thousand is a high enough penalty to inhibit breaking entirely.
You can if you so you control how desirable is to break after binary operators.
Like if I'm sitting ragged. Right. Margins, I often said this to a thousand and never break after.
Or maybe nine hundred. Something really bad. So that I will hardly ever break a formula after a plus sign.
Breaking after a equals sign is another case in which this penalty for parameter seven.
And that's another man breaking after a relation. And similarly, this face was put before and after the relation.
And then this is a penalty to break after the equals sign. V a legal place to break a line.
We'll make in a paragraph.
Typically not as much dois typically you charge more for breaking after an operation and not quite so much for breaking after an equal sign.
And you could, you can set these high if you like, B plus C equals D, the letters B, C and D being in italics.
The space around the A. A relation is a fixed base and doesn't and doesn't have any way to shrink.
It can grow a little bit, but it can stretch,
but it can't shrink space around the plus sign is allowed to shrink all the way down to zero and distress just a little bit.
Question the background. Yes. How to understand the difference between a binary operator and a relational operator.
Does it really understand this formula? It's in a V. There are seven categories of things in a math formula.
Ordinary binary. And there are rules for classifying these things.
Ah ah ah ah. Spell out in the manual. What the.
But everything is classified. Eventually it's one of seven ways. And like punctuation is one of the seven left delimiter right delimiter.
There are seven things when you type that when you type one of your codes,
every code on the keyboard gets mapped into one of those seven case by will by a big table in appendix F,
the first digit of that table tells you whether what what kind of a thing it is.
So Equal Sine was classified as a relation in that table.
Other control sequences will be fine.
What what something is facing or you can say math bean or math up in that net that tells tech one what one of what type to treat.
The thing if I wanted to treat this equals nine as a binary read binary operator.
I could say math been bracket equals close bracket and that would, that would affect on you.
I don't even need the brackets around it.
All right, I you just say math bean equals and that will now be an equal sign through to the binary operator.
Nobody usually uses binary operate,
but which would use the penalty for binary operators and it would also be converted to a unitary if there wasn't anything in front of it.
Things like that. What the space around it around a relation is that is the table Seventy-Seven table in the in the book that
says what space to put when a symbol of one of the seven classes is followed by a symbol of one of the others.
And so here is an ordinary Boxey, followed by a relation that this glue came from the table entry for ordinary, followed by relation.
This glue, this panel. He came from penalty following a relation.
This girl came from relation followed by ordinary. If I had stopped this, the math formula with with a dollar sign right after the equals sign.
I'm not sure if the penalty comes up, but I know that the glue wouldn't come out.
OK. Next comes this Kurn, which is a current which is a space after the after the formula.
And that actually is a legal break. No, no, sorry.
It's not a legal break. No. If a glue if it's followed by glue, that glue is a legal break in.
And the space of the current is also is also thrown away in front of the glue.
There's a break. The question was, when I say glue is a break.
Do I'm in front of the glue or after the wound means the whole glue disappears. And cannot reset to zero actually at the break.
But that's front of the glue. Is a legal break legal by the break in a paragraph.
We talk a lot more about that tomorrow. But that's basically glue.
And at penalties are the mean are the main things. Glue, follow glue has to follow a box in order to be a legal break box or character glue.
Glue file glue is not a legal break. You can never break it.
The second or glue filing penalty is not a legal break. You break it the penalty for not at the glue after.
Now, here's a new thing that gets in there. A rule. How did they get that rule?
Let's go back to my source. Now, we finished the B plus equals D period, except for one thing, the space after the space.
After the period as glue. Five plus point three one one minus point for one one.
That's because that's what I said was the X space skip and space skip is to be used after four any time in space.
Fact I get to be three or more. I think it is this is that this overrides what you would get from the font.
Otherwise the font tells you what space to use after a period. So that's how I got this particular glue.
Next in my thing was a V a vertical rule and I gave it a height of negative three points and didn't mention its depth or width.
OK. No other rules for a vertical rule.
You can now have a negative height, which means that the thing starts three tenths of a point below the baseline.
And then the depth of that rule is going to be to whatever the Barkly enclosing smells, enclosing boxes.
It will extend down to that point wherever this smells and clothing boxes and the width of
the rule is the vertical rule is it is the default here is four tenths and of a point.
So so here's the way the rule specified height of negative three, a depth of star, which means extend up to the boundary and width of point four.
Then came leaders. Leaders is another thing that can appear in horizontal.
You can put leaders in the middle of a paragraph. And the leaders consist of something that goes in the leaders and then unglue afterwards.
Our leaders note should always be followed by glue. As the next thing in the list in this case, the thing in the leaders was a rule,
a horizontal rule of the of the default height and extend as large as long as the leaders go.
The glue here is zero plus hundred thousand points.
What did I actually say to get that? I said leaders H. Rule H fill.
So leaders. This is the thing that goes in in and this is the glue that gets filled by the monarch leaders.
And so that's another thing that can you can stick in a paragraph.
It's possible to break it. The glue here. In which case the leaders would disappear entirely.
Somebody wanted to make a funny looking paragraph where all the spaces in the paragraph were changed into leaders.
They could do that. And then you'd have rules between all the words of the photograph.
But they disappear at the lines, at the line breaks between between one line and another.
Then there's another thing that can go in the middle of a horizontal list. Here I said send zero help.
And send is something that will send to a file.
I haven't opened files zero. So this will actually go to my terminal.
And the text help is going to be the thing that's going to that's going to be sent to the file or to the terminal.
And that guy gets stuck in the in the file here.
And zero help. That's something telling tech that this going to stay.
Stay in there with the horizontal list until this thing finally is put on some page or other.
And then when the awkward routine is pass is looking at this page and mostly typesetting letters and it gets to a send instructions.
That's when it will it will actually do the output to the file.
Right now, the scene just gets stuck in there into the data structure and lived there for a while.
Line break is another thing that a person can see in horizontal. That means force a break at the end of this line right here.
And that comes in as as an Egypt zero in this this print out Egypt.
Zero. Egypt. One is is is when you say Egypt and page break is Egypt, too.
So there's three kinds of Egypt's that can be there. The line break. Egypt zero is saying force a break at the end of this line right here.
Egypt one, Egypt two is page break that says work force, a force, a page break after this line, whatever, whatever.
I'm not sure that I'm at the end of the line, but whatever line I'm in, break the page at that point.
And then Egypt one is combines both of those features. It says break the line here and also break the page here, David.
Things like line breaks in between words to the line break, attach themselves to the previous word.
The line break would occur right there and and it would end. This would be the end of the line.
So this line would end with the century.
In this particular example, the line, a line break, should never follow a space unless you want the space to clear before the break.
If you say space, you know, and then line break. Now, this is actually a good idea if you want.
Sometimes the person that instead of a paragraph in the state of PA, you can say line break, I'm sorry,
you can say like h fill a line break in and then this fills that line and goes onto the next line with that with no indentation.
If you want an indentation, you could also give some kind of a box here that would be indentation each box to 20 points.
Nothing would wouldn't be like this would be equivalent to PA. It's almost almost identical to par as far as tech is concerned.
It would tie two paragraphs together and both paragraphs would be said as a unit.
So for example, if you have hanging indentation that was supposed to stop after seven lines in the
first paragraph was five lines long then then then two lines of the second paragraph.
We'll have a saying indentation and then it'll go back.
You can tie several paragraphs together by this means a paragraph gets longer and take my run out of memory.
If you tie all your paragraphs together because it has to read the whole paragraph in a horizontal mode before it sets anything.
But this way it can be done. And then, for example, if you say loose one around three paragraphs grouped this way,
it will find the best way to add one line to the three paragraphs as a whole.
So this is a way to put space before a library. But if you wanted to if you want a line to come out, a word to come up, flush.
Right. And you give the word in and you say line break before you say space or you say unskilled before that to remove the space.
Arthur, you wanted to love. Are you using the mike?
I suppose what you wanna do is put a black slug, right, justified against the right of a paragraph at the end.
OK. That's something we talk about tomorrow. That's where you want to uspaskich.
We are farfield zero. OK. I'm gonna get through as much as the candidates today before get into paragraphing.
So I said send help, inject zero. And then came what was next in my.
After the line break I said H box please. With questionmark space and a page break.
DDT. I'm getting near the end of this horizontal mode then. So here's an H box that that bracketed the whole word PRCA s question mark.
And that all fit in the H box.
And the only thing that I can mention is that the following glue is the normal glue after's after after letter is not the glue after a question mark.
Normally a question mark would be like a period. It would end the sentence. But since it was in an H box.
This space factor is only one after an H box.
That's an H by space factors reduced to once they use this space here is not the same.
If you would get if I had if I had left out PDAF question mark out of the H box, I would have gotten.
I would have gotten more space after that question mark.
Then came a space in a pay and a normal space and a page break.
OK, so this completes what, the top level it was, say, in horizontal space vector one.
That's the top level of what tech is doing. Knots in horizontal mode.
Ready to accept something else for horizontal mode, whatever you type after the DDT,
still in horizontal mode is gonna be added to this long, silly horizontal list that we've built.
And I've shown you just about everything that can go in a horizontal line.
I think everything, almost everything that can go on horizontal is not not not not exactly everything.
Kernes and discretionary is an hyphenation. Controls ejects, sends all that stuff when you make an extension detec.
You can also. You can also get those things in into a horizontal list of pros and send is is is an example of an extension.
It's treated as if it were an extension to take and and send all this routine of putting send in there.
As it is. It is a typical example. If you ever if you have to look at the code of how how you would make an extension.
That is the effect on the original paragraph, identical to the effect you'd get if one typed in what appears on the second page.
The effect? Well, I typed in all of these obvious macro calls are usable.
The top level, that's left discretion. So I don't have I don't have an easy way to get an arbitrary kearn, for example.
Now, right now, at the top level, not all of most.
Most of them it is. But but there are a couple of cases that are not that are not completely generally.
So right now, then the next thing is vertical mode outside of horizontal mode after it finishes horizontal mode.
What is it going to to put it to pop back to it? And the answer is vertical mode.
And there is a vertical is that there's currently empty in vertical mode and after very vertical mode is the page building thing.
And the things that are haven't yet been contributing to the current page.
And and so they might appear here, but there aren't any things pending in vertical mode yet.
I'm not sure why. Usually the paragraph. Phil, is there.
No. Well, let's see. I better check that out afterwards.
Now, the current page is is anything that's already been put on the current page and there's nothing on that current page.
OK, so now. And nesting level zero is how many lives of races were inside.
And we aren't where we're not inside any Brace's things that were undefined, undefined fonts and things like that.
Greeces So then. OK, then take COMSEC continues on and on and gets to the end of the paragraph.
So after this Didi's woops this to was idea this DDT and comes a display displayed formula and all this is,
this is a complicated and integral limits which I guess the limits underneath the integral sub are the square
root of a over some some garbage here and then a DDT in the middle of the display and then two dollar signs.
There is Lank Line which finished the paragraph for first when I got this double dose,
have started this play, which means flesh out the paragraph as a whole that you've got to up up to now.
So flush that out.
And and at that point we had we had a page break from that which says that you have to break a page at the end of this line.
So that's gonna cause something to be to be output. So that's why we got output.
And this one says completed for page one is gonna show me an exact box that now is is sent out.
So up to the to the line that contains 13, that page bric-a-brac symbol.
All right. Now, the page itself is a V box. The height of the V box is is the is the V size.
They had to set the glue rather high. It's going to stretch a lot because I forced this to break at the place where I said page break.
The first thing you'll see and then begin a V box on the page that got shipped out is this H box with an alien.
Anybody remember what that is? This is the top insert. So the top insert got get put out first on a page because it was to be inserted at the top.
The next thing is this T that's the top step. That's the separator between top insert in there and everything else.
All right. The next thing comes the text on the page itself. Now, here there's glue.
Seventy four point nine eight seven seven. That's so complicated, they won't expect you to figure it out.
But that remember, I said I wanted the top baseline on a page to be a 100 points from the top.
Well, when there's an insert, it also takes it 100 points after it from the top after the inserts.
I'm sorry about that, but that's the way it works.
And the glue here is intended to add to it so that we get the top baseline 100 hundred points from the top.
However, if you look at the next each box and has a height of of ten and so actually whereas the top baseline is not there,
it's that eighty four point nine from the top instead.
Well, the reason is that we also said Max depth was equal to four point nine eight, seven, six, five, four, three.
And so this box has which has a depth, the twenty had to be had to be artificially regarded as if a box was as if its depth was the max depth.
And so what actually happened to this? There's a box that was that was adjusted so that its depth was so that at its height, its depth was was 30.
And so if you add 30 to this, you get exactly one oh four point nine eight.
It's the which is the one hundred plus the nonexempt.
But I'm not going to say any more about it. Forget it. No. That's the.
That's a strange number there. Now this is the.
Anyway. The first line of the paragraph. And and so we've got a lot of dots.
All of this is the first line of the paragraph.
And all of these, by the way, are the V box of the page that was that was sent to the upper routine of a routine.
Want to use this page? It gets this VEBA and all this is the paragraph.
And in the first box on the first line of the box is just the first line in the paragraph.
Let's take a look where that line ended. Let's see.
We got all these people as equals. The everything got on that same line.
And even the leaders. And then in the end and then it and then the line break occurred right after the send, they believe.
And so that's why we got to we got a break right after the sin. And so that line from there to there was just passed out as a line to be typeset.
Next is a penalty. One hundred and four. What is a penalty 104 come from?
Well, that's what we specified was a widow line penalty after the first line of a paragraph.
We got to pay penalty of one hundred and four for breaking a page after.
At that point. But it didn't break there. And we got this glue on the next one.
If you wonder why that line had a depth of 20. It's because of the V box that we lowered by 20 in the line.
Now, the next thing is the glue between between lines.
When we put when tech puts things in vertical mode,
it's got to calculate the right amount of space so that the baselines can't come separated by it, by the amount we specify in the baseline.
Skip. However, this what this previous line had had a depth of 20, so it was had a big thing in it.
So we. So there was no way to to to put the boxes together and maintain the state of baselines.
So this is the line skip glue here. This is the amount that's used instead when you can't when you can achieve the baselines.
Then you put this much glue in between following that as a second line.
And the second line of the paragraph was the please and the fire.
And this is the powerful glue. So the end of a paragraph, what happened?
We had a space here. This was a space before page break. Then then came a penalty of infinity, essentially.
And then the glue that was called powerful skip is in that close at the end of the last line of the paragraph.
So that explains that one. And and it puts the page while it's out putting the page.
It's using basic format. So it's center and center of the page number at the bottom of the page.
And now in this bracket here, one says it's printing page one.
It's now when it says bracket one. Then that means it's starting to two output.
Page one. And when it prints the right bracket, it's finished. Output of page one.
The time if you're watching your terminal, you want to see how much of the running time is going on between the,
you know, generating the text and actually sending it out to the opposite file. That's between this and the right bracket.
Well, during that time, we discovered it was supposed to send the word help out to the terminal.
So this is help here. Then that comes before the right bracket.
You didn't like if you wanted to send a message to the operator, you can you send to send a message.
The operator might get a right bracket after it.
If you don't like that, send a send also a an empty thing and there will be another line on the right back or go to the next line.
OK. Now, Jim, a small question, trying to figure out how the how exactly that page break interacts with the text to DTT.
It's just a display of wherever you are going to display everything.
But it came right up to the page. Yeah, but I hate to break it.
Pacemaker's doesn't take effect until after the paragraph has been justified and broken into lines.
Then the page break mode gets moved out and there's an eject node in the in a vertical list and the vertical is the wind.
When when the page bill that comes along season eject noted that we just saw page break and then read the rest of the photograph.
Yeah. And yeah. Yeah. Because that page break means that justify put the paragraph in the optimal way.
And then wherever that line is in the paragraph, then that becomes that that becomes a place to go to page.
Now the next thing, the next thing I know, we're out of time. But I have to tell you that this is a this is something that we probably bypassed.
So from your exes, from your homework problem, from the displayed math with income.
No add. Through to the end of this, now, the next DDT is in the middle of a displayed math in the end.
We haven't completed the denominator of a formula that's incomplete Minsoo so we can see the numerator, but not the denominator.
And inside a math formula, you have the seven kinds of things Box's binary operators.
Those are the only ones that probably show in this case off is another one up and then they have subscripts and superscripts attached to them.
So a vertical arrow means this is part of the superscripts of this box known and downward arrow is part of the subscript for something.
Here's a box inside of a box with a superscripts of that. And that.
But it's Anasta Construction, a little bit complicated. And this is what happens in math mode.
What before before you got to the end. The end of the formula tech is just building a big tree structure of the formula.
And it's in terms of these no ads. And then after the end of the formula occurs, this tree structure is is passed into horizontal and vertical lists.
And. And the formula is the formula occurs.
So if you are really interested in math, you can see it before and after.
This is because when the tree structure is there, then afterwards,
when you see what actually gets gets sent to the page, this DVD box and so on were built by the math formula.
However, I didn't want to dwell on that in this.
So I'm just showing you that for those who are interested, then at the end of this paragraph came a mark note, which you can only do in vertical mode.
And and then I did an alignment, which is the interesting part of your exercise for tomorrow.
I'll figure out the the meaning of the alignment, because the alignment we're gonna get a V t in the middle of the alignment.
You'll see what an alignment looks like before it's been finished and out in a vertical list.
There is going to be this mark sitting there, which will be which will effect off routine's and so on.
OK. So that's a beginning and we'll see it.
Come on. We have a.